good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast and happy
Tuesday hope everyone's having a
fabulous Tuesday that feels like a
Monday I am sitting down we're back in
New York I'm with my girl Jax and truly
truly what else what more could you ask
for
hey y'all how y'all doing
okay Jackie like is clearly spending so
much time on her fake Tick Tock like her
finsta
user19781 you know okay I sent Claudia a
tick tock from my Fick talk this morning
not because I spend time on it but as
stated and this isn't something I'm
hiding from you guys I do have Tick Tock
app on my iPad if I ever want to like
look at the morning toast fan accounts
and Claudius Tick Tock that's all I
really use it for
um but one of the stories from today
comes with an Associated Tick Tock that
I had to watch and then I had to send to
you to make sure that you've seen it
because it's something you have to see
in order to comment on and that's how I
knew Jackie was like literally living a
lie Hannah Montana two lives with her
user
1987284-3812 account
well something else that's a bit
the other side of me I have a really big
personal update to share with the class
I think I know what it is
um I know you guys aren't gonna expect
this it's kind of the plot twist of the
century given like everything else I've
been saying the last few weeks but I'm
getting a Tesla
yeah okay I thought that was what you
were gonna share so you've been
investigating deep on what type of mama
car you should get and you've landed on
the Tesla tell us why obviously aside
from you know you wanting to like lick
elon's butthole but yeah I thought no
but I wanted to like elon's butthole
when I was getting a Volvo so what
happened what changes no it's that's
what I'm asking you great question
Claude you ask all the great questions
so uh okay sorry so last you guys heard
I was debating between Lexus and Volvo I
was just like waiting for someone to
take me to a dealership so I could make
my choice but then on Friday we had a
guest um come over like one of Zach's uh
family friends and he was driving a
Tesla and I didn't like think anything
of it and he was insistent that I drive
it to lunch and I was like I didn't I
literally didn't ask but I was like okay
you know I do have my license that'd be
cool and I really enjoyed the Driving
Experience not that I spent so much time
driving but it felt nice I liked that it
was like a golf cart where it's like if
your foot's not on the gas the car
doesn't move you don't need to if you're
at a stop sign you don't need to hit the
brake right you just let up on the gas
so I like that and I drive the golf cart
most of the time so it actually be
easier for me to get used to that than
getting used to
a gas guzzler but what really sold me
was he was talking about how safe it is
and how like he knew someone who had
been in an accident in Tesla and the it
was a T-bone accident and the car
actually like detected the accident
coming before the driver even knew and
like so it was able to turn itself a
little bit to like position the impact
to not be so harmful to the driver
um and just all these different like
safety things about it that it's so
heavy even we saw last week that car
that Drew drove off that Cliff did you
see it it was a Tesla a man drove his
car off the cliff with his whole family
in the car he did it on purpose
yeah but the whole family survived oh
good and they were in a Tesla
um so I was really sold on the safety
features and then I was like okay so if
I want to get one like how do I get one
everyone talks about like the wait list
blah blah blah he was like no you just
go online and order one I was like but
if I want to lease it he was like then
you just click lease like literally so
easy and it the way people are always
being so dramatic about everything the
turd it was just like placing an order
at revolve like customized size color
fit payment plan that's so exciting I
will say though
um it's nice that it drives like a golf
cart but I do feel like you're really
like not gonna like know how to drive do
you know what I mean
no I mean I'll know how to drive and
like navigate but they'd say when you go
and drive a regular car it takes like a
day or two to acclimate but well you but
you also have no experience driving a
regular car
but why do I need to learn how to drive
a regular car like this is a future no
for sure I'm just saying like I I in the
future like might be trepidatious of
getting into a regular car that you are
driving that's totally fine if you were
getting into a regular car somewhere
that's not in my house you can take the
wheel how does that sound I would
actually prefer that Jesus take the
wheel well she's away from my hand is
not around then mclared is our second
best choice
that is probably the most truthful thing
you've ever said when there ain't Jesus
there's mclared there is so I'm really
excited
about this journey for me it says the
car is in stock like I should get it in
the next few weeks I'm on the Tesla app
waiting for my delivery date like it's
literally so high tech it's like
ordering it was really like ordering an
iPhone which is crazy and then the best
part of course it's like in Elon We
Trust like now I get to support my boy I
get to have like opinions about Tesla
I'm really excited no there's a big um
community of Tesla owners and they're
constantly fighting about stuff on Tick
Tock oh I'm sorry and the best part the
plot twist of this entry is that I'm an
environmentalist
right I am a green Queen the girl who
like you will have to rip her plastic
cups from her cold dead fingers don't
forget about the straw and her straw is
out here doing more for the environment
than most so people I think that's
that's awesome people do like to come
for me about like the Red Cups I use on
the show and I just want to say like if
you're coming for me and you drive a gas
guzzler I unfortunately can't listen to
you no it's so true like I just
Greta tunberg is literally at her house
shaking right now Greta and I actually
have lunch plans because I'm in that's
so classic the green girl he's going out
for lunch we are the green girly so let
me know if you want to join our club
also another perk is that like I knock
wood like never have to go to a gas
station and fill up my car right
honestly that I don't know how to do I
do not know how to do gas it's honestly
um it's pretty hard like gas I'll never
and that's like different in every state
like it's just confusing it's a lot and
I'm glad to just over that part it's
expensive like I
I don't have to be at the whim of gas
prices right I mean it's all kind of the
same because like electric goes up like
your Con Ed Bill changes oh right you
know so it's like everyone thinks
they're like skirting but no I mean you
could be if you're just like a mooch who
uses public charging stations and not
like one in your house that's so true
but I do think you have to pay to use
the charging station
they're not just like they're for free
really like elon's not a charity oh my
God I literally thought like you could
charge your car for free
I think you I assume you have to pay I
don't know but like that would make
sense you're taking up this place energy
who's paying for it no it's an energy
doesn't grow on trees
no
hmm interesting I'm not sure
no no you definitely have to pay for
that you're obsessed with me like using
public Chargers you're like why do you
need one in your house like just go down
the street like why can't I have one in
my house
because like it's expensive to have it
installed like if that was made like I'd
literally just be using other people's
Chargers like like I feel like they have
them everywhere now like you don't even
need one in your house my charger's not
charging on my Tesla because it got used
to your Tesla instead of mine that's
true so you wouldn't want that to happen
I'm so [ __ ] happy to be home like
there's nothing like your own bed not to
wrap on Tesla talk no no I just like was
sitting here thinking about how like the
last time we podcasted I was in like a
studio that wasn't mine and I'm just
like I'm so happy to be home you don't
miss your La era
no it was like a really good week very
productive
um but there's nothing like being home
I agree with that but I feel like
everyone was really like rooting I feel
like everyone loved L.A Claudia except
for La Claudia well that's the price I
pay for this lifestyle you know like
making others happy before I make myself
happy that's so true
it was great honestly like I'm so glad I
went I said yes to life but saying yes
to life is one of the most tiring things
I've ever done in my life
I know but you have to keep up the steam
like it's only been three weeks I think
you definitely can pause you're not
saying no but you're just saying like
I'm on pause uh I'm saying nothing to
life I think that it's bearing fruit I
mean let's talk about your week
obviously we kept up with you in La it
was such a wonderful experience and you
have two great interviews coming out
from it which we're all excited we all
are excited to watch those interviews
they're really good but most importantly
and the reason why you went was the
49ers game on Saturday which I gotta
play by play already but I was so
invested in you being there and I was so
invested in the game because like was
she a good luck charm or a bad luck
charm I was like feeling really like
responsible for the outcome of the game
now you know how Jessica Simpson feels
yeah I felt like at one point they were
I don't think they were ever like really
losing but like you know the other team
was doing good things got dark for a
second they didn't get dark they were
down by one I was watching like for like
the second quarter they were the stakes
were being made but they weren't ever
like engraved you're like no one was
really worried but the second like
something would go wrong I felt
immediately like everyone was looking at
me and like it was my fault even though
like it's so important to remember
nobody cares about you like not like
that but but you know the things that
you worry about like no one's thinking
about no one's thinking about you as
much as you are but I was like oh my God
I have to get out of this Suite everyone
is talking about me like they're on a
10-game winning streak what's how is
this game different from all other games
me McLarty is there well it could have
been it could have been
so true it was amazing actually you know
what I think it was and it's there's
proof of this it was the fact that I was
watching and I was rooting for the 49ers
because the only part that I watched was
when they started to stink up the joint
and Brock like didn't know his ass from
his elbow and kept running to the left
and then I had to give Harry dinner so I
had to actually turn it off so that
Harry wouldn't like look at the TP while
he eats because like we don't do
distracted eating and then I turn it
back on and it is like a landslide oh by
the way I turn it back on there's five
minutes left in the game and the five
minutes that I'm watching the Seahawks
did score touchdown I shouldn't be
watching it was like an irrelevant
touchdown but yeah but it was like
shouldn't be one I'm just saying because
I was watching like you should not be
the 49ers like couldn't get it together
it was too much pressure you should not
be watching but let me tell you like how
fun it was it was such a I've been to
football games before but I went with
Kristen Kyle use check's wife and we sat
with George Kittle's wife Claire and his
family so I really like came at it from
like the family
um side of it and I was just thinking
like there's it was so nice it was so
fun like everyone flew in from like Ohio
all over and they're so proud of their
like husband brother son it was so nice
like I it felt like so much more was at
stake because it's like the family it
was so nice and then last night Ben was
watching football and I was watching
with him and I was really thinking I'm
like oh my God all these guys like their
parents must be so proud of them like
they're so talented so it was really
like coming at it from like this
wholesome side it was so nice and
they're so it's actually crazy how like
I just assumed like if I was you know
married to someone in the in the league
like I would go to every game and like
get wasted but it's like when they were
doing poorly like the energy in the
suite was like bad like they were like
quiet and I was like oh man wait we're
like not drinking but then like when
they would start to pick back up it was
like yeah like let's drink and like take
shots and like you know make tick tocks
the energy is like so incumbent upon
what's going on in the field and like I
get it it's an important game but I'm
like
let's party yeah YOLO YOLO it was so fun
though and I just
I'm such like a like a well-versed
sportscaster now that I could really
I think I could see myself working in
sports
I think that's something that you should
aspire to I think they need you I think
you need them
you should let me tell you you should
like call your agent and try and get an
audition
football is like actually interesting
you know I'm not like I was watching the
49ers game and then last time me and Ben
watched the Cowboys game and when I tell
you like I was actually interested like
that [ __ ] is pretty good it's pretty
entertaining I too found myself
interested this weekend like I was
watching Harry but I couldn't look away
I have some notes because
they shoot okay but it's like the time
like time to play and it's like first
down they shoot the field from the side
and while I think that might be like
decent it would be so much more helpful
if they had the camera behind the
quarterback so you could see what Tom
Brady sees you know what I mean
yeah and last night when I was watching
like a couple times they shot from
behind Tom Brady and
Prescott
and I'm like this is so much better like
I could see everything I could see what
the quarterback sees yeah but the fans
see it from the side so are you a fan or
are you a quarterback
well the not all the fans depending it's
360. yeah no I was just like damn why
are they not shooting from behind the
quarterback all the time or at least
like most of the time
I could I understand I think they switch
it up they get a little crafty with
their angles you know they have their
portrait mode they're trying they really
don't like when they have their drone
but when the game is in play they're
always shooting from the side it's
actually not an effective way of
shooting football I do have a degree in
cinematography from the New York Film
Institute but I think also like they
need to stay the [ __ ] out of the way
like that I think they can I think you
could literally stand in the stands with
those high-tech cameras and get behind
Tom Brady
okay I think that you can't just like
change how the whole game is watched not
at once I know I just got here to the
football Community but like I am
pursuing this so like that's a change
that's you like coming in as a new
driver and getting a Tesla you know but
like these people have been driving like
gas cars for so long they can't just
like make a switch all of a sudden well
sometimes it takes a fresh set of eyes A
New Perspective and that's what I
provide here okay maybe we should start
our own sports network where the whole
thing is filmed from your POV TNN plus
because for me if if we were filming
from my POV like I want eyes on the Wags
and I want to know who's that whose wife
whose girlfriend who's kids whose
parents the facial expressions who's
hanging out with who I want wag TV well
let me tell you how I actually discussed
at length with Christian use check the
term wag and she did say she doesn't
like it and she didn't seem like a
weenie who's like she's not she's not
like a weenie who's like easily offended
she was like I don't know I just don't
like it and you know what I actually
agreed like to diminish a person to the
occupation of their partner like it's
[ __ ] but I just wish there was a
different word that's the word that's
what I was going to say I can respect
that I just okay so what's the word tell
me and it's like
yeah what's the word wives and
girlfriends
black no I need a term yeah I am I'm
happy to swap it out just Wags really
rolls off the tongue so it's gotta be
like
good like that well so now I want to ask
you I don't know if you know this so
last night was the Tom Brady Buccaneers
versus the Zach weinerb Cowboys and the
Cowboys won it was actually such a
fascinating game like the Cowboys they
were playing really good but also like
the Buccaneers were like I actually
genuinely could have done better myself
like really bad job on everyone's part
mostly Tom Brady but everyone else
um and now that means that the 49ers are
playing the Cowboys next so I'm curious
where that leaves Your Allegiance
because you come from a Cowboys
household but this brand was built off
the back of the 49ers
hmm
when do they play each other this
weekend I think so or like at the Super
Bowl no not at the Super Bowl like next
week that's the next game yeah [ __ ] I
didn't know I'd have to make a choice so
quickly I hoped it would turn itself out
um I mean I'm gonna take a different
look at it and it's a win-win for me
because I will be happy with whatever
team wins like if the 49ers win like
amazing those are my people like here we
go we get like more content if the
Cowboys win amazing my husband's happy
like this is so exciting and they're
doing amazing things so I just wish you
know like they were playing other teams
first and that the game like one of them
isn't knocked out so soon because it's
nice to be invested in two teams my odds
are greater of being happy so true very
positive outlook I'm extremely positive
when it comes to sports
and then it also just made me think
about Tom Brady last night because he
was playing this game you know he's the
oldest man on the field and he was
stinking it up like really genuinely
like very badly
um and I just feel even more Resolute I
feel like when we talked about him
coming out of retirement I did say that
this like was very loser energy for him
and last night he was quite literally a
loser a person who loses and it was just
kind of like sad I'm like you really
should have stopped like you really
should have stopped when you were tired
you're just kind of like disgracing your
legacy and just because like you might
have had a few more like good years than
you doesn't mean you need to do it you
know
yes and this is for Giselle most people
would agree with that and I think I
would be one of them and go out on top
you know go out strong but like what if
he just loves playing football and he's
like I don't need to be the best on the
field I just want to play the game and I
want to play it at a high level like I
don't want to be scrimmaging in my
backyard with my 12 year olds like I
just well that's nice football even if
I'm not winning Super Bowls I made it to
the playoffs and I'm the oldest man on
the field like what if it's just like I
want to play play ball no that's that's
definitely possible I just think with
Tom Brady there's so much more at stake
like you're no it's like he has like and
that would require like no pride no ego
you know right none of that just like a
love for the game I'm not saying that's
his mentality but if it was that's
something I could respect it's like just
because I'm not the best anymore doesn't
mean I don't want to still do the thing
that I love and that I loved my whole
life okay that's really nice it is but I
just don't see that being the case it's
really nice though I think I should be
his PR and that's the angle he should
take yeah no because that's refreshing
like it's vulnerable and honest yeah
normalize not being the best but doing
what you love but don't be like terrible
and he's not terrible he's he made it to
the playoffs he's fine
he's lost in the first round and like
pretty much everyone okay but plenty of
quarterbacks like lose it's okay
yeah but not Tom Brady that's what I'm
saying like Okay why does he why can't
time Brady mean so many different things
he because he doesn't like that's just
facts but he gets to decide what it
means
okay and now it means losing is that
what he wanted everybody is he having
fun
no he was not having fun last night like
literally the anger every time the
camera went to me put his head down like
he didn't want to be seen it was shame
this shame I mean it's also doubly
shameful because we all know that he
gave up his wife for the sport his
family loving him back right now
right but I think I'm someone who
believes that like you could be a great
football player and be happy to be in
the game even if you're not winning the
Super Bowl
that's so sweet it's literally so sweet
um I don't agree but it's it's a
beautiful story and I just think if he's
gonna do any interviews like where
someone wants to roast him about like
the choice he made he should use this
line I think it would play like really
well with a lot of people yeah no like
you know
play to their hearts you know he'll
touch people and make you think like
just because you're not the best anymore
doesn't mean you have to be out of the
game
yeah like he could still throw
things are going well yes
so that's just kind of my like football
recap of the weekend I'm really like
getting into it you know that's your
game tonight I'm getting into it too I
think so Emma oh no today's Tuesday oh
that's why there was a game last night
oh Monday Night Football there we also
game the night before and the night
before there's a game every day now
which is exciting for us football fans
yeah but I don't think there's a game
until Saturday now yeah I've not heard
of Tuesday night football
maybe that's Thursday night they sound
similar whoa Tuesday night
oh
Tuesday night
kind of kind of slays yeah there's a lot
of football coming up and I don't see
our interest waning
no I mean the 49ers are now playing the
Cowboys um like I'll be
like I know this is how it feels to be a
football fan like I'll just be so upset
if 49ers don't make it to the Super Bowl
I think they'll be even more upset where
are they playing
49ers
damn you should have gone to that one
no I feel oh I feel so good about my
decision I know I tortured everyone last
week about like bird in the hand one in
the bush playoffs lose eagles fly I feel
so good like I took a risk and it
actually worked in my favor like not
only did the Eagles win so I got to go
to the game
the 49ers won like everything went in
the way that I had hoped that it would
and that never [ __ ] happens to me so
chase your dreams you know take risks I
love that we're so risky
it was giving Risky Business
you know yeah it was and how was your
outfit did everything come together in
the way that you had hoped I thought you
looked great it did my jacket that I had
ordered online last minute arrived right
the day before the game at my hotel in
San Jose it was literally everything's
coming up cloudy everything is coming up
clouding it's such an amazing thing so
we got
we got winners we got Teslas we're kind
of just coming off like a like we're
just like a bunch of winners it's kind
of transformative weekend for your girls
like we're different people than we were
we're die hard football fans we're green
environmentalists and that just goes to
show like you you think you have us
figured out and then we go and change I
think that we should change the name of
the show from the toast to the tune for
Greta tutenberg
I think so too and and every day it's
just a plea to have her on the show and
I mean what's more environmentalist than
me not even having a car because I care
so much about the environment and the
one car we do have is a Tesla I mean
like no one's doing more for me in this
country right now than us you literally
can't say anything to us
about our job try and talk to me about
my footprint try yeah sure doesn't even
and you know what I never leave my house
so I admit very few emissions and I
don't need a lot of meat
but enough you know because I'm a human
being
um I'm not you know a cow who's gonna
eat grass all day I am a cow
uh I think it's really good stuff
we're kind of like entering our green
era
look at our plant-based wallpaper
we're just like supporter of plant life
that's literally and we've been we've
been literally advocating for the
mcplant for years
and and
today's episode is brought to you
by Branch Basics which is kind of
entering our green ERA with us just
ushering us into the green era tell us
about the branch Basics class for our
fellow green girlies and Aspire and
green girlies yeah for our fellow
toonies
today's episode is brought to you by
Branch Basics non-toxic hypoallergenic
and free of fragrance and hormone
disruptors and harmful preservatives
Branch Basics are baby and pet safe
they're clean and cost effective so when
you have people in your house like Theo
like Bruno like Harry you can't just be
using any sort of Surface Cleaner or
detergent they're filled with chemicals
things that are bad for us bad for the
environment if you want the safest and
the best ways to stay clean around your
pets and babies check out Branch Basics
one concentrate it can be used for
everything it makes laundry detergent it
makes hand soap it makes dish soap it
makes all-purpose cleaner it makes
bathroom and floor cleaner it literally
replaces every single cleaning product
in your home and they offer the refill
model which is once you run out the only
thing that you need to repurchase is in
concentrate and the oxygen boost it is
so much less wasteful than having like a
million different cleaners for your
laundry for your counters for your
bathroom for your shower it's the
all-purpose concentrate it is one
product that you can use everywhere in
your house it is super clean and safe
again free of fragrance hormone
disruptors harmful preservatives it is
baby and pet safe it is clean and cost
effective
so Branch basics for me personally has
been great because I don't have a lot of
storage in my apartment so I don't have
like these big cabinets where you could
put like all your different glass
cleaner like all this crap I have Branch
Basics I use it in my laundry I use it
in my kitchen I use it in my bathroom
it's so effective and it's really great
if you're trying to minimize on how much
like products chemicals and just like
plastic you bring into your home if I
may for me my Branch Basics has been so
amazing because when I first had Harry
so I would use like my toxic cleaning
supplies for me and the adults and I
would get I got baby stuff for Harry
every dish load we did separately like
Harry stuff our stuff laundry loads
Harry stuff our stuff and then we got
Branch Basics which is a clean cleaner
and it's great for babies and it's great
for adults and now we can wash
everything together Surface Cleaner for
his high chair and for our table like
you don't need to use two separate
things and also like I shouldn't be
using that many chemicals either like
I'm a green Queen Branch get 15 off any
starter kit when you use code the toast
at branchbasics.com we recommend the
premium starter kit for all of your
cleaning needs that's code the toast for
15 off today's episode is also brought
to you by third love most bras suck and
it's a real bummer third love third love
knows that you're not the problem it's
the bra so they spent years designing
bras for your body they make over 60
sizes and even invented half cup sizes
so you always get the perfect fit which
means you'll always look and feel great
so if you're looking for an everyday bra
something with more coverage or an
unlined style do you need an extra lift
all of the above third Love's
best-selling bras are here for you they
are all designed to fit and support your
body they have a style for every
solution and for every outfit they will
make you look and feel great in whatever
it is that you're wearing and they're
available in half cup sizes for your
perfect fit so thurles genius technology
in my opinion is getting you the right
bra size and I feel like we all went to
like bra stores when we were 13 got our
boobs measured and have been wearing
that size ever since it's so inaccurate
their quiz online is really in-depth
they ask you about like your brush your
boob shape how your boobs fall what's
not working with your current bra and
you will finally for the first time in
your adult life know what size boobs you
actually have so also it's important to
note that your bra size can change over
six times throughout your life so they
make it really easy to find the perfect
bra size with their virtual fitting room
it is a personal shopper but better it
looks at the size the shape the fit
issues it's helped over 20 million women
find their perfect bra size so ditch the
bad bras get a better one that makes you
look and feel great upgrade your bra and
get 20 off your first order when you go
to thirdlove.com toast that's 20 off
your first order today at third
t-h-i-r-d
love.com slash toast thirdlove.com
t-o-a-s-t
great thank you so much you're welcome
to the toonies our first story we are
starting with some Sunbird
are you gonna Dive In
oh yeah but I usually do that before the
yeah
you did a native
um segway I did a native Segway and um
we were just like chit chatting I didn't
want to delay like you're talking what
else oh okay yeah no sorry I got thrown
off by such your organic
segue into our organic cleaning products
right because like organic lifestyle is
very much like a core tenant of the
toonies and of the toast and that's like
so beautiful so beautiful I mean we can
dive in I'm totally ready because we
have some great stories some people that
you're friendly with so like want to
hear your take on things
um see what you saw in La Okay saw
anything that we should know about
um and I think without further Ado yeah
I could dive in anything else so you
wanted to share and oh I know you're
watching Mindy projecting or loving I'm
watching mini projects and I'm loving
but I have to say two things about it
the first of all the amount of cameos on
this show is insane I don't remember it
being on but it must have been huge at
the time Kris Jenner was in an episode
last night Laura Dern like so many and
then I'm watching who has a guest Cameo
Josh Peck
he plays ray-ron I was like dying
um new episode of good guys just dropped
and then
oh I was shook you know who else had a
cameo
it was so many it was 2013. I think
juicy sommelier
I forget that before he was like a
disgraced liar who lied about a hate
crime Jesse Smollett was a working
working actor I forgot and I I don't
yeah I guess it's a cameo because he had
like a small role but he wasn't coming
on his like you know anything other than
just like an actor and a show yeah no he
was not coming on as like a celebrity
Cameo he was coming on as like a guy who
got the job right right not like Kris
Jenner no no playing herself right
exactly it's jarring I've never seen him
act in anything
I have to check his IMDb Jackie you
would love this show actually really
Olivia and Shapiro would love it Ben
loves it so much we Hackle we were up
till two in the morning watching it like
the it is so funny and Mindy just writes
from like the POV of a chubby person
perfectly like it's so [ __ ] relatable
how like literally her entire life
revolves around her weight which is
literally how it is when you're like a
self-conscious fat person like of course
it's so on point like it's hilarious and
it's got heart you know what made you
start watching it why that why now why
that it just dropped on Netflix I saw
him because I follow Mindy on Instagram
she said like so it's like I guess it
was a big deal that it moved from Hulu
to Netflix
um and then it was just on my thing and
me and Ben were in La we weren't like
looking to commit to like a serious show
and I'm like I'm on season four already
I'm devastated like I love this show
like you love a sitcom
I do love a sitcom
and they're kind of like a Dying Breed
yeah but I feel like Mindy like really
brought a modern
um take to like the age-old sitcom
really there's no laugh track
thank God but it's actually like there
should be a left track because it's
actually funny no that's why there isn't
one because you don't need to be told
one to laugh so true so true and it's
just like really out of pocket humor
like she goes like she goes there like
she has like a lot of Jewish jokes a lot
of like jokes about race like she's
really going there
um I don't find it offensive like I find
it refreshing like it's funny you know
yeah that's funny as long as you know
we're joking about everyone
no she goes after everyone cool
um I actually just finished my book last
night which is a really uh Buzzy book
right now
um it's a really Buzzy book right now
called demon Copperhead it's like very
literary serious it was an Oprah's Book
Club pick and I think it's like having a
moment on the best sellers and
everyone's talking about this book and
it's so good it's really long and it's a
difficult book to get through because
it's just like a sad long story that
doesn't really get great but I thought
it was so important and if you're
looking for like a
a real book A book that's like a real
novel
demon Copperhead like so good I told
Dana to read it it's a Dana's choice for
sure I have not read like in a few weeks
because I just like you know when you
just can't
yeah well that's what was happening to
me a few weeks ago and I just like
watched a ton of TV but all that TV like
I had nothing to show for it it was
making me like more angry and depressed
well that's because you're not watching
the mini project
because I wasn't watching The Mindy
Project no because I was watching like
the Fleischmann right depressing trash
everything is depressing that's why I
turned away from the TV but we just got
a huge TV installed in our bedroom so
now I'll be able to see if the character
is wearing a Jewish star and acting
nefariously
um but it's almost like too big like I
feel like unless I'm watching you know a
movie that's like a real movie what am I
doing watching Miss Rachel on this TV
you're living your best life don't come
from a Straight Talk No but it's like
I'm just saying like it's so big you're
gonna die it's like a projector I'm
excited it's a projection room above the
auditorium
hell yeah okay now where I feel like
we're good to dive in
let's do it our first story is some sad
news that happened Thursday
um evening Lisa Marie Presley has passed
away
um and she will be honored with the
public memorial service at Graceland
nice so the lead singer Sunday service
will take place on the front lawn of men
of the Memphis estate on 9 A.M page six
has confirmed uh her daughter her
daughter Riley keough's rep told page
six that the actress her grandma
Priscilla and her half siblings Harper
and Finley are grateful for the support
well wishes and outpouring of Love
honoring Lisa Moraine Elvis's daughter
died on Thursday at age 54 after
suffering cardiac arrest in her
California home she died at West Hills
Hospital and medical center after being
placed on life support and they
confirmed the passing in a statement to
the AP on Thursday
um okay so I've now ended up on like
Lisa Marie Presley talk and
am I the only one who like maybe if I
had thought about it I would realize
that Lisa Marie wasn't related to Elvis
daughter oh Elvis's daughter oh sorry
sorry sorry
but I thought it was Priscilla's
daughter
Priscilla was Elvis's wife and together
they had a daughter oh sorry but who's
the other one
okay my things confused sorry okay
disregard what I just said
um so sad that Priscilla Presley has
like lost her husband and her daughter
in her own lifetime like that's not how
people are supposed to live
yeah also this story like so I read
Priscilla's Memoir and I've had such an
Elvis year so I'm like very like just
into the family and the story I find
it's constantly confusing me because
like Lisa Marie is so was so young and
like so on her death is so untimely that
like I keep thinking it was like
Priscilla but it's like it's not it's
just so crazy and so sad that this
person died in this way at this age like
it's just not supposed to happen like
that especially like before your parents
like it's so sad also like her son Lisa
Marie's son Riley's brother
um died by Suicide a few years ago so
it's just been like oh
a a life filled with up some trash no
that is really sad and I agree I get
Lisa Marie and Priscilla like kind of
confused too
um
it's so sad and I feel like it's so like
the timing is so weird because this is
like the year of Elvis for everyone you
know yeah she was just at the Golden
Globes she's actually been I feel like
more public not that I followed her
career really but I don't recall a time
seeing her as much as we've seen her now
that she's been with Austin Butler at
all of these premieres and all of these
award shows and she's constantly talking
about how proud she is of the film how
it really captured this Spirit of Elvis
like the whole family is so into it it
was really like a year the Year of Elvis
you know since his passing like for the
modern era and
just to get this news like a few days
after we all saw her at the award show
on the red carpet like it's it's tragic
it's tragic the timing is so bizarre
um now that everyone's talking about
Priscilla Presley she's like very much
infiltrated my Tick Tock feed and the
way I forgot she was married to Michael
Jackson that interview there's a lot of
like big fun facts that you that like
keep slipping my mind and then they come
back and I'm like whoa no that interview
where they're sitting together and Diane
Sawyer Queen is like asking Michael
Jackson why he has little kids sleep in
his bed and Priscilla's just sitting
there like it's that's like a moment in
time it needs to be seen Lisa Marie is
sitting there oh wait
no wait which one buried Michael Jackson
Lisa Marie Oh I thought it was Priscilla
like after Elvis
no okay sorry the way I cannot keep this
family straight that's what I keep
saying like it's it yeah it it's so at
least some confusing
okay this whole time I thought it was
Priscilla Lisa Marie was married to
Michael Jackson
yeah because they also look alike yeah
as you know mother sure do
and there are so many different like pop
culture points for both of them
and a lot of it happened before our time
so you can find out about it now and
it's like it's it shocks you again if
you've never seen clips from that Diane
Swire sit-down interview where they're I
don't think oh my God it's tar like they
talk about just everything like because
they got like a shotgun wedding people
were really shocked I think at that time
um a lot of people thought that Michael
was gay and this was like his way of
proving that he wasn't by marrying like
the gorgeous you know daughter of rock
and roll king and so they did this weird
interview because like they dated for
like four days before they got married
and everyone was shook and then Diane's
going after him like why do you have
kids in your bed and she's just sitting
there it's it's something to say
and I wonder when all that Michael
Jackson stuff came out a few years ago
after the documentary like did anybody
get a comment from Lisa Murray that's
interesting
I don't know uh also she's the mother of
Riley Keough who will be playing daisy
Jones in Daisy Jones in the sixth and
she has two other daughters who are
twins
um from a separate marriage not Keo but
now there's three girls that's so sad
about a mama it's really sad and the
three girls will be left Graceland that
is theirs oh so Riley Kia like owns
Graceland
a third of it with her sisters because
Lisa Marie was Elvis's only child right
yeah so I think this really shook up the
nation everyone I know it's like been a
few days but I it's just so sad yeah
so
are you ready for our next story which
is a twofer a duper
a twofer because it's under the category
of
rumored celeb couples that I'm not
totally buying okay
first up Selena date Gomez in the
slightest in the slightest Us Weekly
reports yeah from us let's just change
the source
okay just let me consider the headline
how about that
Selena Gomez is dating The Chainsmokers
Drew Taggart following his split from
Eve jobs says Us magazine new couple
alert US Weekly exclusively reveal they
aren't trying to hide their Romance by
sneaking around at members only clubs an
Insider told US Weekly noting that the
pair are very very casual and low-key so
where's the picture so where's let me
say how I don't believe that this is
true and if it is true I hate this
literally hate
I agree this makes no sense no like
Selena is this is just it's not true
like I don't even want to waste my brain
cells it's not true I'm sorry I like how
suddenly we're all you know re
revering US Weekly as a like a sore but
like US Weekly could have the exclusive
on like a hot new couple whatever it's
just not this one like I can't think of
two people who would be were suited for
each other I feel like The Chainsmokers
like you know party party they've got a
lot of girls yeah on their phone like
and Selena is a business has a stage in
her life where she's ready for a
committed relationship she's always with
the beckhams they're a married couple
she's not bringing around like her
boyfriend so I saw a clip of
um Selena Gomez on watch weapons live
maybe 10 years ago and Andy asked her he
was like the rumor is is that Brooklyn
Beckham broke up with Chloe Grace Moretz
because he was so Smitten by you can you
confirm that she was Selena goes isn't
he like 12 and that's literally the like
first time they've ever commented on
each other publicly and now when you
look at that knowing that like she's
literally a threesome with Nicola and
Brooklyn it's so weird
yes I saw that too but that's a really
good response like that makes me feel
like no they were no I don't think there
was anything going on but then I was
also I don't reminded of Brooklyn
Beckham dating Chloe Grace Moretz
forever
I forgot I had forgotten as well and
also I just like forgot about Chloe
Grace Moretz
yeah
yeah
I was thinking about her the other day
Where She Went
literally no idea where in the world
she's Chloe Grace Moretz she's hanging
out with Addison on the Amalfi yeah
um so I don't believe this for one
second
if they can get a picture of them
together like walking maybe they're
working on a song together like
literally it would be business not a
relationship no way no how no way no how
like I need to see a wedding photo of
these two to believe it
and I still wouldn't I would be like
it's beautiful literally
um maybe they do have a new song though
coming out and like this is the
beginning of the pr stamped to make the
song big and that's like how PR business
works and I could accept that
I'm too excited
and I would say that's good PR even
though no one would buy that these two
are dating even though they're age
appropriate they're both into music
they're both like really big and rich
and famous that it makes sense no it's
incorrect like I don't I don't need
proof I just know in my soul it's not
happening
it's like you ever watch are you the one
yeah we watch [ __ ] it's not a perfect
match
if they went to the truth food yeah it
would be an x 100
oh bring back are you the one
subset B of this category of young
Hollywood dating rumors Chase Stokes and
Kelsey ballerini are rumored to be
dating and she's giving a cryptic
response to the rumors on her Tick Tock
that I sent you this morning so she's
not stoked about the rumors Kelsey
ballerini gave a cryptic response to
recent speculation that she's dating
outer base star Chase so actually this
article is entirely misleading her
comment actually had nothing to do with
the rumors that she's dating Chase
Stokes it had to do with something that
was posted on tomorrow about her
know about the rumors no but the rumor
she was referring to is about her trying
to date the guy who runs Soho House in
Nashville
no but like in the so it's a green
screen of Kelsey on together and it's
dumwa screenshot and it's like the first
thing is Chase stokes's photo Lil recap
and it looks like him and a girl and
then so it's like about chasing Kelsey I
don't know what the other things say
below no no oh no no that's not how I
interpreted it at all she literally
pointed to the dumwa item
um that hold on let me pull it up that
says Oh I thought she was pointing to
the whole screenshot no because somebody
wrote like the most moronic thing like
how the [ __ ] would you know that about
Kelsey ballerini and that's what she's
commenting on she's consistently this
she said Kelsey ballerini can't be
dating Chase jokes because she's too
busy consistently asking out the manager
of Soho House Nashville when she comes
in all the time
like how do you know that first of all
second of all what she's saying is like
this rumors moronic she's not even
commenting on the chase thing Chase
posted a photo of them and they appear
to be like maybe kissing under this hat
like they're definitely seeing each
other and that's cute and that's great
got it I thought she was like saying
like the whole thing no and the rumors
and and then her response what she said
in The Tick Tock is I know I know I know
stop reading stop reading stop looking
but what is happening guys what let's
not do this and then she captioned the
video I'm about to break up with the
internet five sure yeah she was talking
about that really random blind item
somebody submitted to dumois that she's
like desperately trying to go out with
the manager of Soho House Nashville
got it okay so if what Claudia is saying
then she's saying no to that but leaving
open yeah she is stating Chase Stokes I
thought she was just like rolling her
eyes at the whole internet like with
their rumors about her and she wasn't
confirming or denying anything just like
look at this no because honestly the
chase jokes thing isn't a rumor like
nobody was thinking anything until he
posted a photo so like they're basically
like announcing like we're seeing each
other we're hanging out
let me go look at the photo that he
posted and also apparently they were
flirting on Instagram like comments with
each other cute yeah and then they went
I think to the TCU Georgia game they sat
together and somebody snapped a photo of
them from the back she's under his head
I think maybe they're like kissing
um any tags or posted it like he's
sharing the potential new relationship
it's not rumors it's we that's a hard
one nobody would have known
that's a hard launch that's what the
kids call it
not soft soft would have been no time no
tag right
so
this is different from the Selena thing
Selena thing is purely speculation we
have no proof literally Chase Stokes no
one was thinking these two were anything
until he literally posted a photo and
everyone was like wait what this is so
Random I'm obsessed I ship
yeah let's discuss I definitely ship I
think it's actually a really good
pairing
yeah I don't know why maybe because he
plays a high schooler on television I
would have assumed he was much younger
but I think they're that's the same
exact age
the only thing I'll say is that she was
duetting with Gavin DeGraw this weekend
and
my ship lies in that port
um I could you know take a break a
little yacht trip on the chase jokes
yeah I do reside and I own a ship of
Kelsey and Gavin like when will it be
Gavin's turn such an important question
I like went I feel like it was Gavin's
turn like early 2000s and and like that
was the time when he was like fresh on
the scene everyone was obsessed with his
music One Tree Hill
young starlets
was he even for lack of a better term
pop and puss
I have to I have to imagine I hope I I
do think so like the early 2000s were
crazy he was literally like the biggest
thing on the music scene definitely he
was definitely catching puss
okay I hope so at least and I hope that
he has love now and is just being
low-key but according to google like
there's nothing maybe like Chase is just
like a rebound you know post divorce
having fun relationship and Gavin's the
guy who like you don't see it first he
helps you through the dark time and then
like when it all is said and done and
you're ready to settle down and get
serious you realize that love has been
in front of you the entire time
a hundred percent I saw her perform
something too it looked amazing
it's amazing and they're both like so
musical they both seem like really down
to earth people and I think when you're
your life is so musical it's important
to have a partner who shares that music
out I could not agree more like for you
like you and Ben are both really music
we're both I mean like Ben's not as
talented as me but it's probably better
though
no but he like loves music yeah he does
and could you be with someone who like
didn't love have a love of music I could
actually because like I find that when
Ben sings like I find it annoying
like I almost I almost wish he wasn't
musical just like shut the [ __ ] up and
listen to me
I guess that but it also puts people in
constant competition with one another
and I feel like with after Morgan she's
like no more music no more competition
because I do think like her success and
his like you know kind of failure to
launch a little bit definitely
had a an impact on their marriage it
couldn't have been easy
no it couldn't happen that's why she's
like okay posting CMA Awards like Bell
of the ball at everything country music
and I think he had a heart really hard
time being recognized just like as a
soloist
yeah but the thing is he is really
talented so it must also like be
frustrating I could see that I could see
their fights being like well you're not
a real artist totally I will say Morgan
Evans Kelsea ballerini's ex-husband is
genuinely one of the most talented
country music artists his first album is
that makes it works that makes it worse
you know at least if he were like
playing at music he could be like happy
for his wife but when it's like That
Should Be Me
That Should Be Me playing Gavin to grow
100
okay I'm glad we got to the bottom of
that so I feel like now she's like yeah
somebody else I'll go with an actor
somebody else
and Chase Stoke seems like a good guy
yeah really nice Ben actually knows him
um he's a lovely lovely fella
I get good vibes not like Austin Butler
no negative vibes
our next story is some more relationship
drama because Miley Cyrus dropped a song
on Friday called flowers and it is
definitely about her ex-husband Liam
Hemsworth and there's a lot of tea in
the song and then subsequent tea that's
like rumored to be more crap about the
song but basically the song is like a
play on Bruno Mars is When I Was Your
Man and I don't get why we have to bring
Bruno into this and trash is beautiful
but here we go because Liam Hemsworth
dedicated that song to Miley at their
wedding
yes yes no I understand it was like
their song but now she's just like
wrapping apart Bruno's lyrics and it's
like okay so everyone knows the Bruno
Mars song If you don't Claudia do you
want to Grace this with you know it
hurts hurts I'll be there from the
beginning first to say that I was wrong
oh I know I'm probably much too late to
try and apologize for my mistakes but I
just want you to know
oh
I hope he buys you flowers
and hold your hand gives you all his
hours when he has the chance take you to
every party cause I remember how much
you love to dance do all the things I
should have done when I was your man
it's really such a sad song
it is it's about all his regrets and so
Miley is literally going in the chorus
word for word and trashing Bruno's
lyrics so Bruno says I hope he buys you
flowers she says I can buy myself
flowers and he says and hold your hand
and and she said she can write my name
in the sand and talk to myself for hours
say things you don't understand shady
and then should have taken you dancing
she said I could take myself dancing and
I can hold my own hand yeah I can love
me better than you can so I just want to
say and I realize how this sounds coming
from the mouth of like a Taylor Swift
Stan apologist but like enough with this
breakup like it's been years
okay but she's not like really spoken
out I feel like actually she has like
I'm Oh I thought like no when I think
about why did Miley and Liam divorce
after like 10 years of this like
gorgeous courtship it's literally like a
little Sparks novel
um I don't have an answer but now with
this like things are coming out so first
of all obviously like she's like
trashing him to filth and then people
are saying like he cheated on her with
14 women in the house where she shot the
music video in the video she's wearing a
suit at one point and people are saying
it's a suit that he wore to The Avengers
premiere when he told her to like stop
okay to come down Avengers premiere is
like where yeah like I didn't know about
that did you know that I did the Clips
are like constantly going viral Miley
was just like having fun at this
Avengers premiere like being her crazy
wild self like taking pictures
grinding on Liam and when they're doing
interviews and when they're taking
pictures there's like a couple moments
where he like literally grabs her and
it's like stop behave yourself like
you'll pay for this later like people
read his lips he's like he's not into my
is like free spirited attitude
whatsoever
I hadn't seen that and even if the lip
reading is a little off like you see
what happens she's like being her crazy
kooky self he says something to kind of
like bring her down her face kind of
Falls for one second and then she picks
it back up and she pushes him aside and
she does her own pictures like it really
is kind of a beautiful moment for Miley
and it's like Miley takes no [ __ ] but
you could tell that it bothers her
quarters and she's a [ __ ] human being
yeah and that's [ __ ] rude no it's
rude to be like that positive fun person
like sometimes you know like I'm a loud
person like you're being so loud like
I'm just having fun [ __ ] off
yeah imagine Ben said that you had a
party like can't you just behave
yourself for once oh my God the way his
neck would be slit like
right so that just like made me sad and
made me obviously realize there was
bigger things yeah sure maybe Miley's
personality and out thereness isn't for
everyone but like you chose to marry
this girl like take her as she is or
what are you doing 100 like he was
definitely trying to make her into like
the type of wife
he wanted not the type of wife that she
was but like I don't think she ever lied
about who she was like we all I could
have told her no 100 she's a free spirit
do you see the bro do you see the
bangers tour did you see Miley Cyrus and
her dead pets like she's a free-spirited
girly
what did you think you were gonna get so
um
I I'm not obsessed with this song like
at all
I like it the first time I heard it I
was like okay it doesn't feel like a
single Bop to me it's like something I
would hear on an album but then after
here listening to the lyrics more and
when I was your man thing and like
that's the fact that there's like a lot
of meaning it's not just like a song
someone else wrote for her I'm really
into it I feel like it's it's good I
like it I'm and then snitch liked it so
that made me like it for me like the
song that Miley released where she
addresses the Liam thing that's better
is slide like I love that song
okay cool it's more like the era I'm
comfortable in when it comes to Miley
okay I'm glad you're comfortable yeah
but I think the song is doing really
well it's all over tick tock
yeah and I like I'm I'm happy for her
especially if she has you know things
she needs to process from her 100 Art I
never really think of her as a divorcee
they were together for so long but they
were not married for so long
right but like still she has an
ex-husband and she wants to talk about
it literally so Chic to have an
ex-husband like
ah
could be you but like I don't want it to
be like I do wish I just like had
married someone before Ben like some
losers because I don't want a divorce
Ben I love Ben but like I kind of want
an ex-husband like it's kind of like a
Birkin like it's a fabulous accessory
yes you know what you could do which
could even be more fabulous if you
divorce Ben and then remarry him it's
like very Elizabeth but I'm not a
divorcee then
you're not no like I would have consider
NeNe Leakes a divorcee like even though
her and Greg literally got divorced and
then got married again
okay I like the creative angle but like
I'm definitely looking for like like I
just want to be like a woman who has
like you know previous lives you know
but like I've literally like live in the
same city I've lived in my whole life
I'm sorry you'll never be that
mysterious because we do this podcast
every single day no but like maybe like
before I started the podcast like I had
this whole other life where I was like
chain smoking cigarettes and like
marriage when you were when you were
trying we started podcasting when I was
like literally 21.
um but still like I just I yearn for
like a sexy mysterious past and then
like I'm in France like you know on
vacation and I run into my ex-husband
and it's just like you you know you'll
say to me like who is that that's my
ex-husband and just like and it's like
well they won't go it's a Parisian
vacation we've really moved on and we
like kind of see each other for what
each other was which was just like this
young kind of moment moment in time
um but I could just you know turn to my
Parisian friends when they ask who that
is I say it's my ex-husband you know
okay but now think of it differently
like you could be in the era right now
where like this will one day be your
mysterious past where like she was a
podcaster at the top of the charts then
where did she go she's in Paris with her
new husband okay Benjamin like like I
don't like I don't see it that way but I
really you're so positive today and I I
don't want to discourage that like
you're right like no but like this could
be the first chapter and it's a pretty a
strong one like she's famous she's like
with Leo but she stays with her husband
like you know she could have
James Mars yeah but she chooses Ben and
then like right what happens next it
could get crazy no I love like I love
that
yeah think about it but still you the
same problem poses where it's like if
you want to be interesting you gotta
leave it I know and I won't but I just
feel like there are actually a lot of
people perhaps listening to the show who
are divorced and it's like they feel
like it's a Scarlet Letter and I'm here
to tell you like it's fabulous it's
fabulous it's Chic it's giving like I
don't know why like when I think of like
my ex-husband like I think of like
skinny girls chain smoking cigarettes
with big Birkin bags that like they beat
up because they have so many Birkin bags
they don't need to like treat them well
yeah and when you say it like that
instead of talking about like your ex be
like my ex-husband yeah like oh who's
that over there oh that's my ex-husband
and his new wife
yeah just say it like that it changes
everything like life is all about
perspective so you could either see an
ex-husband as like this this like
mistake or regret or you could see it as
a successory
and I'm telling you
if you look at divorce as like an
accessory and just kind of like a fun
fact on the resume of your life
I don't think you'll regret it
that's beautiful Claudia thank you
are you ready for our next story is it
brought to you by Squarespace
yeah it's actually brought to you by
spare space love okay so from websites
and online stores to marketing tools and
analytics Squarespace is the all-in-one
platform to build a beautiful online
presence and run your business
so
whatever you're looking for when it
comes to e-commerce or creating a
website but you don't have like a lot of
knowledge because most of us are not
software Engineers Squarespace is an
amazing place to start it is so easy to
get a website up and running they can
help you with pretty much anything that
is required when starting a website
whether that's your domain whether
that's design they have like so many
easy templates people are going to think
you hired like a fancy company when you
literally did it at home with
Squarespace and you used our code to
help you out so whether you have side
hustle or your business is online or you
want to get into e-commerce I have used
Squarespace many times in my life I feel
like I'm always making websites like for
back in the day like my blog and then
the podcast I do and I've used a lot of
the platforms out there and I can say
Squarespace is really one of the better
ones it's so user friendly if you don't
have a lot of experience using
um like website design it doesn't matter
like it's really user friendly
so if you are looking to launch an
online business looking to elevate your
website
check out squarespace.com toast that'll
give you a free trial and then when
you're ready to launch use the code
toast to save 10 off your first purchase
of a website or a domain again that's
squarespace.com toast for the free trial
and then when you're ready to launch use
our code toast to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or a domain
squarespace.com toast today's episode is
also brought to you by Caraway new year
new kitchenware with Caraway start your
year off right with non-toxic
kitchenware so you can ditch the
chemicals and make healthier cooking a
piece of cake with our exclusive
discount you can now save on the full
Suite of Caraway products including food
storage the tea kettle the mini cookware
I feel like whenever we Vlog on patreon
you get to really see how Caraway has
infiltrated both Jackie and I's life as
somebody who lives in New York and
doesn't have a lot of space I love their
easy to store Solutions like there's no
more missing tops or just a crap all
over a drawer they are designed to be
stored really well which is why I like
it also Jackie's cooking for rolled in
there they're non-toxic kitchenwares so
they're designed for the modern home and
they feature a chemical free ceramic
coating food is prepared with peace of
mind knowing that no hard to pronounce
chemical compound is going to leach into
your healthy ingredients all of their
sets come with easy access storage
solutions so that no stacking is
required gone are the days of misplacing
your lids
so visit carawayhome.com toast10 to take
advantage of this limited time offer of
10 off your next purchase the deal is
exclusive for the toast listeners so
visit carawayhome.com
toast10 or you can just use code toast10
that's toast10 at checkout again Caraway
non-toxic cookware made Modern
carawayhome.com toast10 or use code
toast10 at checkout
thank you McLaren welcome
yeah I use Caraway and I have a Tesla
what like what I'm trying to know about
try me
our next story Prince Harry's making
history his Memoir spare sets the record
as the fastest selling non-fiction book
of all time Prince Harry's tell-all
memories Memoir spare has shattered the
record for the fastest selling
non-fiction book of all time the Duke of
sussex's revelatory account of the royal
family and his personal life sold a
whopping 1.43 million copies during its
first day on sale in the UK U.S and
Canada according to Guinness World
Records Harry's book sales blew away the
former record holder which was former
president Barack Obama Who Sold 887
000 copies on his release day uh
that's why old and then I thought it was
interesting the the hot most fiction so
that was like for non-fiction but for
fiction the other Harry holds the record
Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows how
many guess how many and on its first day
Jesse Hollows that was like the last one
right
I you're asking the wrong person two
million but probably
8.3 million on its first day that's
345 833 books per hour you have to see a
canceled Queen out there doing her thing
yeah crazy number okay so it's Harry D
house that's actually very interesting I
I don't really care
um but I'm glad you brought this up
because I want to talk about we got like
a lot of backlash on our last episode
talking about Prince Harry's book like
you guys didn't even read it first of
all who us first of all I just I just
want to say like if you left a comment
like that like shut the [ __ ] up I'm not
reading this dumbass book because you
told me to I like I'm protecting my
piece how can you talk about a bucket
and even read open a [ __ ] newspaper
that's what everyone's doing nobody's
actually read this book [ __ ] so I just
wanted to say that because I was like
reading these comments I'm like my God
people are so dumb they're so ugly and
stupid and I just really wanted to say
that
no but I thought I said a number of
times maybe I need to say it again one
like we were reacting to the headlines
about the revelations from the book and
even when we would read quotes from the
book I said a number of times I don't
want to be a broken record and I said
but maybe in the context of the book
like there's a different vibe but like
this is the poll quote but again if I
read the book I might come out with a
different takeaway like I feel like I
said excerpt which is true like ex like
episodes that's the thing about anything
like everything requires context but at
the end of the day like here's what he's
revealing that's like straight racks
maybe it's part of a larger message that
wasn't included in the article but like
here's a little juicy story about Kate
and Megan and we're gonna and we're
gonna do with that what we want and like
you guys can chill I feel like the
Prince Harry like stands think that like
Prince Harry's gonna come and like lick
their vaginas like he's not listening
like you don't have to defend him so
much chill out he's not gonna [ __ ] you
like chill he loves his wife Megan
you would know that if you read the book
he loves his wife I think more than any
has ever loved a wife yeah no and the
thing is like the excerpts are all over
the Internet so you're telling me unless
we've read the book we're not allowed to
talk about it this is a free country
[ __ ] the first amendment is freedom of
speech [ __ ] I think is that number one
yeah freedom of expression so like shut
up like I'm so dumb with people telling
me like what I'm doing wrong like shut
up this is my [ __ ] podcast go
away
and hope and thinking that you might
change what you're doing yeah because so
and so because Prince Harry Stan 801
said I can't talk about it since I
didn't read the book so I'm not like
shut up I'm so done like seriously [ __ ]
off like literally go away
ugly rat
agreed but I did want to talk about this
sales yeah because it's so huge and okay
and then like people were like oh like
I'm sorry when it comes to Prince Harry
people are not [ __ ] okay and I know
that a lot of people feel very defensive
of Meghan Markle and I really do
understand that I don't understand this
like obsession with Prince Harry like
chill he's not even from this country he
doesn't like you shut up but people were
saying like because you and we were
saying the other weekend I do really
believe that this is true like the
American sentiment I believe towards
Harry's definitely shifted in the last
couple of weeks like the constant press
the constant like excerpts the
interviews it's really started to rub
people the wrong way I think even people
who supported him and so when this
number came out you know people are like
well Claudia and Jackie said that like
they uh said that like Americans like
don't like Harry anywhere but like this
number is like obviously like not
indicative of that uh actually I
disagree like you could still hate
someone and buy their book hello
to me it shows how much people just care
about the royal family in general like
we've never gotten a memoir from a
high-ranking member of the royal family
like
purchasing and like there's so much
royalty in it it's like you really have
to if you care at all like of course
you're gonna read this book why wouldn't
you unless you I don't know I mean I
guess I do care maybe I will read it
eventually
um but I'll see like what what people
who I know think about it like I'll take
a recommendation if someone someone you
respect you would love it yeah yeah like
I've seen some people that I follow
reading it so I might just be like what
do you think like is it worth reading I
um my next Memoir is going to be Minnie
kalings I've heard they're incredible
that's perfect for you
um
I think actually I'm going to do another
non-fiction after this as a follow-up to
demon Copperhead about similar subject
matter because now I'm in this of course
uh anyway so I think this I mean I
expected the book to do well obviously I
didn't think it would be the number one
non-fiction book of all time and that's
pretty cool he must be extremely pleased
with himself and penguin Random House
must be happy too no this was a major
success on all fronts depending on what
your barometer for success is like if
you want self-respect if it's about like
money and sales yes if it's a
self-respect like image but like
honestly we add a number like this like
it kind of Trumps self-respective like
all that you put out there about penis
and your family like the ways you
dragged everyone in your life it makes
it worth it
I think it does like because that you
hold your Guinness Book World Record
holder yeah congratulations
not everyone can do that
and that's a big of achievement well
actually I'd be curious to know that is
a big achievement but I would want to
know the highest non-fiction book of all
time because like some you know unknown
authors they don't have a big first day
of sales but they could write an amazing
book that like people just keep and keep
buying so I'm just gonna google that I
mean Colleen Hoover
right she didn't sell a lot on her first
day no her books popped off years later
yeah
okay the oh no
these are like editorial the best ones I
said most popular the Bible
John Grisham did they sell on the first
John Grisham
how much that's not non-fiction oh we're
thinking well and I'm also curious what
did um
Jeanette McCurdy do because she was
breaking sales selling out on Amazon too
yeah second printing the whole thing but
I went like first day versus all time
okay this is going to require more
research research because um it's like
best and I didn't say best I don't care
what you thought was the best yeah
because obviously it would be open book
by Jessica Simpson obviously
um really happy for Harry Megan has been
so quiet I wonder what's going through
her mind
I think well one of Terry's mom yes so I
think she's letting her husband have his
moment and it's not a spotlight that
she's done to me under right now because
it's you know
it's not the most flattering night I'm
gonna be honest fluorescent
yeah
um are you ready for our fifth and final
story
which is a little exciting Sports
Marketing celebrity news it's a triple
right
the NBC Olympics logo for 2024 Paris
games has been unveiled with Paris
Hilton's help huh she is the face of
their Paris Olympics 2024 campaign so
far they put out a little teaser video
of like Paris for this summer olympics
and it's starring her okay like the
other the other Paris what is the logo
oh it's just a really fancy uh rings
with um like a cursive pretty font it's
less so I mean the logo they think we
care but it's really about the fact that
they taxes and to be like the face of
their NBC Paris Olympics coverage and I
think it's so smooth and I'm shocked
that this made it through all the Hoops
tell me about the Paris Olympics is it
winter or summer
summer when is it
summer 2024. prior
that's a really far time away like not
them trying to get hyped up for the
Olympics it's literally in 18 months
literally I thought it was gonna I
thought it was good I assumed it was the
summer too I I didn't think about when
2024 is
ew anything like literally so much can
happen oh my God okay but the we always
say that but then the Olympics just like
sneak up on us and then they're here I
do feel like it's been a long time since
the last Olympics no we just had like a
turnt Olympics like a year ago
like a year ago is winter yeah
um I'm ready for the Olympics like one
thing about me
I [ __ ] love the Olympics no I'm gonna
put an asterisk I'm ready for a fabulous
Olympia yes because we've had a couple
of forlorn Olympic Seas plus with Kobe
and then like the families couldn't come
it was just like [ __ ] depressing and
they were in places where they like have
to bring in snow and it's like why would
you get the Olympics if you don't even
have to know but I think Paris summer
summer maybe I'll go
that could be Claudia in Paris except
like that's really not a way to see a
city no Mexico definitely not but I
agree the Summer Olympics are so
fabulous and Paris is such a fabulous
City and we got the gymnastics and the
swimming I'm I mean like I'm annoyed
that we're talking about this because I
wouldn't have thought about the Olympics
otherwise and now I'm just like excited
for something that's literally not for a
year and a half
well you could watch the commercial and
get like just be happy to see that
commercial and that like Paris is
working with NBC and NBC respects the
hell out of how they do I mean Paris to
show
that's true and Kathy's on housewives
yeah no they've actually weirdly become
like a big part of the the NBC Universal
brand in the last couple of years
yeah that was also like do you see that
Paris was uh becoming the face of Hilton
Hotels I mean it's high time like the
way that the brand is so synonymous with
the family and the family has not been
involved in the brand like in a
financial way in years like Rick Soldier
yeah they sold it yeah but like so they
put her in the commercial for Hilton
Hotels and I thought as they should and
I know when she travels like she'll stay
at a lot of like the really nice
International Hiltons and I'm sure she
gets it for free and she's always
tagging but like their partnership
should be more more
robust I think Waldo Astoria owns yeah
so
um I'm sure she stays at the wall I
think Hilton owns Waldorf Astoria if I'm
not mistaken
oh which one's the filter
no but which one oh yeah because I guess
then you're Hilton Hilton Honors yes
exactly Astoria that's how you know who
the head exactly is
like a Marriott owns Ritz Carlton
Waldorf is positioned as the flagship
brand within Hilton's portfolio yeah
owned by Hilton
good great
um so love ever Paris love to see you
know our girly out here shaking her
thing
and summer 2024 can't come fast enough
Paris can't come fast enough
um so those are the past five you
definitely need to know most I wouldn't
say all
um which ones would you say you didn't
like that last one honestly
you haven't seen the video maybe maybe
that's it but like you know it's so far
away
like a story about a video that we can't
like play on the show like you know
oh I disagree I think this the the news
was that like Paris is getting the
respect that she deserves so good so
good
that's our show y'all nice long one for
you catching up from the weekend we're
back tomorrow hope you guys have oh yeah
our memory cards are about to run out
thank you guys so much for listening to
the toast the millennial Morning Show
where we deliver the past five stories
that you need to know every Monday
through Friday on YouTube so if you're
watching this on YouTube please feel
free to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcast can be found so
at Spotify iTunes Stitcher public radio
I got rid of cast box all the places so
every listen to podcasts find us the
toast sleep at five star review about
how beautiful stunning and smart we are
and of course
talented hope you guys have an amazing
Tuesday that feels like a Monday and
we'll see you on hump day bye
bye